und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne
gellineck guten Abend der Vorfall ist
beklemmend und er zeigt dass Israels
Ziel der Militäraktion die Hamas zu
vernichten und die Geiseln zu befreien
dass dieses Ziel schwer zu erreichen ist
gestern erschossen israelische Soldaten
versehentlich drei junge Männer die sie
eigentlich hätten retten sollen obwohl
die drei Geiseln unbewaffnet waren und
ein weißes Tuch schwenkten ein
schrecklicher Fehler der Israel erneut
aufwühlt gleichzeitig gibt es Berichte
von einem Treffen zwischen Vertretern
von Katar und dem israelischen
Geheimdienst die über die Freilassung
von entführten verhandeln sollen aus Tel
Aviv berichtet Susanna San
zeusende kamen heute Abend in telaviv
zusammen dass drei Geiseln durch
israelische Soldaten versehentlich
getötet wurden hat viele erschüttert und
bestätigt es müsse mehr dafür getan
werden um alle Geiseln frei zuubekommen
129 sind es
noch was für eine düstere Woche wir
kriegen die entführtenen Särgen und
Leichensäcken zurück es ist
entsetzlich mein Herz blutet es tut mir
so leid für die Angehörigen und für die
Soldaten die diesen schweren Fehler
gemacht
haben eine der Getöteten Geiseln wurde
heute beerdigt große Trauer in Israel um
drei junge Männer die vor den
hamasterroristen entführt worden waren
und nun durch israelische Soldaten
starben wie konnte dieser tragische
irrtumm der Streitkräfte Passieren der
General Leutnant versucht zu
erklären die Soldaten treffen auf viele
Terroristen die sich als Zivilisten
kleiden sie müssen auf in
Sekundenbruchteilen entscheiden es kann
der Unterschied zwischen Leben und Tod
sein der Militärchef räumt aber auch ein
dass es einen Verstoß gegen die
Vorschriften gab Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu zeigt sich sehr
betroffen sie standen so kurz vor der
Freiheit und dann dieses disaster das
hat mir das Herz
gebrochen das hat unserem ganzen Volk
das Herz
gebrochen in Gaza gehen die Luftangriffe
und Bodenkämpfe auch heute weiter und
immer wieder Beerdigungen und Trauer in
ran Junis um einen Kameramann des
Senders aljasira der durch einen
israelischen Luftangriff ums Leben kam
der Krieg fordert viele Opfer auf beiden
Seiten fast jeder in Israel kennt einen
Soldaten der jetzt in Gaza kämpft
Israels Streitkräfte sind buchstäblich
eine Volksarmee Männer ab 18 leisten 3
Jahre Wehrdienst Frauen zwei nach dem
Überfall der Hamas wurden sofort
hunderttausende Reservisten einberufen
sie ließen Familien zurück die die
Anspannung kaum aushalten können Anne
Brühl
berichtet gelobt sei der allmächtige
Gott der König des Universums der uns
befiehlt Hala vom Teig zu teilen es ist
keine gewöhnliche Frauenrunde kein
gewöhnliches Backen Rut Adriana und
Rebecca sind Soldatenmütter ihre Söhne
kämpfen in Gaza halalat zu backen ist
eine jüdische Tradition für Frauen ist
es verbunden mit einem persönlichen
Gebet
niemand sieht unsere Kinder als Kinder
oder als 18 19 20jährige Jungs die am
liebsten Fußball spielen würden oder
surfen oder mit ihren Freundinnen
zusammen
wären die drei Frauen kennen sich
seitdem ihre Söhne zusammen im
Kindergarten waren sie haben alles
gemeinsam erlebt Ausflüge Urlaube
verliebt sein jetzt versuchen sie sich
gegenseitig Halt zu
geben es ist schrecklich es gibt keinen
Weg in Kontakt zu ha ke Kommunikation in
Gedanken sind sie immer bei den
Kindern was Gott verhindern mag wenn sie
jemand töten müssten das ist etwas ich
glaube das kann niemand sie sind dazu
nicht gemacht so haben wir sie nicht
erzogen so sind sie einfach nicht das
ist sehr
verstörend von einem aber sind alle
Frauen überzeugt nach dem Überfall der
hamass auf Israel gibt es keine
Alternative zu diesem
Krieg Rache zu tun es geht um das
Überleben des jüdischen Staates und der
Juden auf der ganzen
Welt ich weiß nicht die Art wie die Welt
unsere Kinder sieht das ist sehr
schmerzlich für mich denn wenn wir nicht
dort sein müssten wären wir es
nicht sie alle waren in den letzten
Wochen auf Beerdigungen bei Kameraden
ihrer Söhne manchmal auch zusammen mit
ihren Söhnen du siehst buchstäblich wie
dein Sohn zusammenbricht und dennoch
versuchst du dich zusammenzureißen weil
sie keine Wahl hab
haben deshalb müssen wir Sie
unterstützen sagt Rut der Gedanke dass
auch ihnen etwas zustoßen könnte
erlauben die Frauen sich
nicht lass uns darüber nicht sprechen
wir sprechen nicht
darüber in der Wohnung von Rut brennen
immer noch die hanoka Kerzen Licht das
die Dunkelheit erhält nichts sagt Rut
brauche sie gerade
mehr und auch diese gab es heute von
wuhsdorf in Niedersachsen aus startete
ein Airbus der Luftwaffe nach Kairo an
Bord Brutkästen Beatmungsgeräte und
andere medizinische Güter für die
Versorgung von Patienten aus
Gaza es ist der wohl schmutzigste
Wahlkampf den Serbien je erlebt hat im
Privatfernsehen wird ein Politiker der
Opposition beim Sex mit einer
ungenannten Frau gezeigt die
Landmaschinen eines anderen
oppositionskandidat gehen in Flammen auf
der serbische Präsident Alexander wuit
hat vom großen Bruder Russland gelernt
und den gesamten Staatsapparat auf
Stimmen für seine Fortschrittspartei
eingeschworen über die morgige
Parlamentswahl in Serbien Britta
Hilpert an der Technik soll es
jedenfalls nicht scheitern zta macht
eine
wahlgenprobe 3000 Beobachter schickt die
NGO an die Wahlurnen hier sollen sie
melden wenn dort geschummelt wird denn
rasad nedjelkov traut der Regierung viel
zu Druck auf die Wähler
Medienmanipulation Missbrauch des Amtes
oder öffentlicher Ressourcen von den
Regierungsparteien das sind die größten
Probleme so steht Alexander wusic als
Präsident gar nicht zur Wahl ist aber
ihr sichtbarster Wahlkämpfer diese
Kundgebung läuft live auf über 30
Kanälen mehr als 260 mal war wuic in
diesem Jahr live im Fernsehen so zitter
die Opposition war wesentlich weniger
sichtbar die Botschaft stehts wuic
bringt Wohlstand und
Stabilität das Volk spürt die Gefahr
dass die schlimmsten wieder an die Macht
kommen wollen um Serbien in die
Vergangenheit zu führen die Botschaft
verfängt vor allem auf dem
Land was W macht es phänomenal und die
Opposition eine Null eine Katastrophe
ich will nur Frieden und ich liebe wuc
weil er so viel
Macht doch wuc fördere eher ein Klima
der Gewalt meint das Oppositionsbündnis
zwei Amokläufe im Mai mit 18 Toten
formte es ihr Leitsatz gegen Gewalt denn
der Zusammenhalt leidet meinen sie weil
der Präsident einen permanenten
krisenmodus pfliegt dazu dient auch der
Konflikt im Kosovo er eskaliert wieder
auch weil serbische Gewalttäter
rechtfertigt die Serben im Kosovo
ertragen nicht mehr den Terror von Kurti
sagt er mit Blick auf den Regierungschef
des Kosovo dazu dient auch die opferpose
gegenüber der
EU immer wenn wir etwas ablehnen was der
Westen will sagen sie sie werden uns
isolieren dragangilas von der Opposition
meint die Presse sei größtenteils
Russland freundlich und W wolle auch gar
nicht in die EU er brauche sie als
für einen nationalistischen Politiker
ist das die einfachste Art an der Macht
zu bleiben all diese Feinde hassen uns
der Westen die EU die USA so schafft man
eine Gemeinschaft und gewinnt
Wahlen Wu Partei hat gute Aussichten die
Wahlen zu gewinnen schlechte Aussichten
sind das für die
EU und wir machen hier weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Heinz Wolf und kehren da
noch noch mal zum nostkonflikt zurück ja
und zur Lage am Roten Meer dort hat ein
Zerstörer der US-Marine mehrere drohen
abgeschossen es habe keine Verletzten
oder Schäden gegeben das zuständige
usreionalkommando teilte mit die drohen
seien aus von Husi Rebellen
kontrolliertem Gebiet im Jemen gestartet
worden die hui hatten zuvor erklärt
Gebiete in Israel angegriffen zu
haben vor der Küste Libyens sind bei
einem Schiffsunglück offenbar viele
Migranten ertrunken die UN-Behörde IOM
in Libyen spricht von mindestens 61
darunter Frauen und Kinder immer wieder
sterben flüchtende bei dem Versuch das
Mittelmeer zu überqueren allein in
diesem Jahr hat die Behörde bereits etwa
2500 gestorbene oder vermisste Menschen
registriert Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
plant eine teilreform der Schuldenbremse
es sei vorgesehen die sogenannte
konjunkturkomponente zu überarbeiten die
bei einem Abschwung mehr Spielraum lasse
sagte Lindner dem redaktionsnetzwerk
Deutschland das habe aber nichts mit der
aktuellen Haushaltssituation zu tun eine
grundlegende Änderung der Schuldenbremse
wie von SPD und Grünen gefordert lehnt
Lindner weiterhin
ab der Umweltbonus zur
e-autoförderung endet mit Ablauf des
morgigen 17 Dezember danach können keine
neuen Anträge mehr gestellt werden hat
das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
mitgeteilt bereits zugesagte sei nicht
betroffen und würden ausgezahlt dass der
Umweltbonus früher endet war seit der
haushaltseinigung der Ampelkoalition am
Mittwoch bekannt zunächst war aber kein
konkreter Zeitpunkt genannt
worden in Hessen ist der Weg frei für
die künftige Koalitionsregierung von CDU
und SPD die Sozialdemokraten werden
damit nach einem Vierteljahrhundert
Opposition wieder in
Regierungsverantwortung gehen als der
kleinere Koalitionspartner die
jeweiligen teigrämien von CDU und SPD
stimmten heute für den Koalitionsvertrag
den die neuen Partner am Donnerstag
vorgelegt hatten er soll dann am Montag
unterzeichnet
werden ein gerecht im Vatikan hat in
einem finanzprozess erstmals einen
Kardinal zu einer Haftstrafe verurteilt
das Gericht verhängte im Verfahren um
verlustreiche Immobiliengeschäfte gegen
den Kardinal Angelo betchu eine
Haftstrafe von 5 Jahren und 6 Monaten
beteuerte seine Unschuld und sein Anwalt
Anwalt kündigte Einspruch gegen das
Urteil
an es ist eine unendliche Geschichte vor
fast 50 Jahren kam die Idee auf ein
stillgelegtes
Eisenerzbergwerk zum entlager für
schwach und mittelradioaktiven Müll zu
machen Schacht Konrad in Salzgitter
sollte erst
1988 dann 91 97 und schließlich 2012 in
Betrieb gehen ein dringendes Wasser kam
dazwischen zuletzt sollte das Depot 2027
eröffnet werden vielleicht denn
inzwischen sind die Zweifel gewachsen
dass das Bergwerk wirklich sicher ist am
Dienstag könnte der grüne Umweltminister
die Genehmigung wiederrufen Oliver
deuker berichtet aus Niedersachsen
Ursula Schönberger und Ludwig wassmus
wohnen in Sichtweite von schachtkonrad
waren von Anfang an dagegen die
stillgelegte Grube als Endlager
auszubauen ihre Argumente das Projekt
stammt aus den 1980er Jahren ist mit den
damaligen
Sicherheitsanforderungen und den
damaligen Rechenprogrammen und so weiter
den Möglichkeiten damals berechnet
worden
es wird nicht Rück soll nicht rückholbar
eingelagert werden
es soll höhere Grenzwerte für die
Langzeitsicherheit geben also im Prinzip
das ist ein Projekt das ist aus der Zeit
gefallen das sieht Thomas Lautsch anders
der Bergbauingenieur und Geschäftsführer
der bundesgesellschaft für Entlagerung
ist verantwortlich für den Ausbau von
Schacht Konrad seine Argumente dafür der
Tiefe Untergrund von Konrad ist dicht
also trocken er ist stabil und wir sind
sehr tief dort nämlich 1000 m und damit
haben wir die Grundlagen dass ein
entlagersystem funktionieren kann die
technische Planung ist alt sie wird aber
ständig aktualisiert und auf den
standertechnik gebracht Argumente hin
oder her Politiker fast aller Couleur
aus 30 sowie drei kreisfereinstädten und
Gemeinden stehen kritisch zum Endlager
fordern in einem Brandbrief an
Niedersachsens grünen Umweltminister die
vor Jahren erteilte Baugenehmigung zu
widerrufen das ist uns ganz wichtig dass
es nicht heißt überall nur nicht in
Salzgitter sondern wir wollen eigentlich
ein faires Verfahren nach
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen und
nicht wie damals eine politische
Entscheidung getroffen wurde am Dienstag
nun Tag der Entscheidung vor dem
hintergrundlicheus Fesser mit
radioaktiven Material auf die
Entlagerung warten das ausfüschacht
Konrad es hätte weitreichende Folgen
jeder der
cononrad politisch in Frage stellt muss
ich auch gleichzeitig der Frage stellen
was geschieht dann mit den Abfällen die
schon existieren die schwach und
mittelradioaktiven Abfälle die heute
schon über 100.000 Kubikmeter ausmachen
lagern in Behältern die nicht Langzeit
sicher ausgelegt sind das heißt man
nimmt sicherheitsabstriche in Kauf die
jedenfalls mit einer
Krad beantwortet wären heißt es dringt
die Zeit in Computeranimationen läuft
die Entlagerung perfekt die Realität
sieht anders aus immer wieder verschiebt
sich die Fertigstellung des entlagers
2027 sei nicht mehr zu halten heißt es
und die Baukosten steigen von 4,6 auf
nun 5,5 Milliarden
Euro und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr 2 7 12 22 31 48 Superzahl 3 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto. zdfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 die Wetteraussichten für morgen im
Norden stark bewirkt und örtlich etwas
Regen sonst teils sonnig teils neblig
trübe oder bedeckt an den Küsten
stürmischer Westwind 2 bis 11° am Montag
teils Sonne teils Nebel ganz im Norden
Regen 4 bis 11° und danach zunehmend
unbeständig bei 3 bis
10° das war's von uns an diesem Samstag
hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
Aktuellen Sportstudio zu Gast bei Jochen
Breier ist Bundestrainer Julian
nagelsmann und um 025 Uhr gibt's dann
die nächste heute Express und morgen
erwarten Sie hier Heinz Wolf und Donja
Hayali einen schönen Abend tschüss
wiedersehen